got a question right here from a guy
named Jean gu looks like an Islamic
state like pizza but John it's up Johnny
Johnny Johnny
totally gay best friend I saw a question
for Burt given that Theo is in a 12-step
program and a big part of that program
is acceptance and forgiveness do you
think that you would ever forgive Ari
Shaffir for unintentionally drugging you
and giving you Molly so hopes here back
gang gang - good question
very no he said he said unintended I
think that's where we differ thank you
pretty direct in his intent do you think
he wanted to do it like just do you
think there's something in him that's
like I got to get a rise somehow out of
things and it doesn't matter what it is
it doesn't matter if it's like you know
uh just his vibe of humor with the COBE
stuff you know like heard not just Kobe
but all that go into the edge you know I
got a douse my friend I got to do this
fire I mean I think I think the two are
separate I think but I'll say number one
I think always always succeeded on those
outer barriers of comedy media I'm
really pushing the edge really finding
the boundary and then and then jumping
over it yeah case in point the the Kobe
thing the the I'm not gonna go through
Ari's list of the things there but even
the picture of him naked on the stage
like he's always at the you know he's
always done the / he's always he's doing
the Dark Side of the Moon a lot of time
yeah 100% I think I do think there's a
part I think there's a part of already
that thought if we do a podcast and I've
sliver Molly it's gonna be the most epic
podcast ever yeah and everyone's talking
about the further Esther their lives and
I think he I think that was a part of
his thought process but I do think that
part of his intent was this is gonna be
a blast first one of my best friends I
Molly's not gonna kill him I'm gonna
give him Molly we're gonna get high
we're gonna laugh we hang out all night
he didn't really calculate it like he
was like I should have checked to see if
kids were in the other room I should
have checked to see if they make dinner
or something my wife was making dinner
for all both of us wouldn't
with the girls because my girls love
dari mm-hmm and uh and and he's like and
he didn't check that I was flying that
night I was starting my tour that night
so there's a lot of things I didn't like
check the boxes for he just kind of did
it and and it was mean it's super
regrettable because I still love Ari and
I and I'm we're still friends we text
all the time we talk on the phone but
like if my daughter sees me texting with
Ari still take my phone she [ __ ]
Georgia hate sorry
LeAnn hate sorry and that's what [ __ ]
sucks and that I'll never release the
podcast because I just don't I know for
a fact already thinks it's a pig but
I've talked too much about it so if you
watch it yeah you'd know too much about
my feelings about what happened I
suppose if I had never spoken about it
and I just released it I would have been
I mean it would have but I think it
would probably got off without a hitch
but I talked about it so much
mmm that I just I feel like it's not
fair to show it's not fair to show re
being somewhat insensitive to a friend
who believes he was drugged and may die
right cuz or he's just he's high and he
doesn't care and I'm freaked out I'm
having a panic attack and you can
definitely see all that and I know Ari
feels differently but will you one day
put him on a paywall you think no I mean
maybe it maybe one day like releases a
movie
may I may I mean it's by the way it's
not it's so crazy like if you say you
heard you like others outtakes on
Reservoir Dogs where they lose memory
there's I'll takes on Lily Tomlin losing
her mind on Dustin Hoffman or someone
during a movie totally I think you see
something and they were like oh I want
to see that and you as a fan as a fan of
podcasts as a fan like a perfect example
right when you and bill bird at a
podcast and everyone was like bro what
the [ __ ] happened there I went right
there excited I watched it I didn't see
what I think everyone else saw like I
just saw you and Bill hanging out it
didn't didn't register for me the way it
did for other people but I ran right to
it I I ran right to it people on Twitter
what what the [ __ ] happened with Bill
and Theo and I was like Bill's one of my
best friends I've know the I feel is one
of my close friends like I've known bill
for 20 years I've known Theo for 15 yeah
I'm [ __ ] I'm going here for me it
didn't like razzle-dazzle me I can see
what people were talking about I can
pick up on hints of it but like it
wasn't what I want to see so I know as a
fan the idea that you'd want to watch me
and re me get drugged I'm just afraid
protective of re that especially with
all the Cobie [ __ ] the one yeah but we
just it wouldn't help anyone really
wouldn't help any trust me man had I
released it in that Kobe [ __ ] gone viral
people would have grabbed that and it
would have here it's lugging us a white
guy I mean do I'll tell you right now
when it happened dr. Drew said you know
just so you know you by you telling me
this I have to call the police and I
went then I made it up then I don't know
what you're talking about so if I put it
out there would have been I think it
would've been a bad I already disagrees
100% Wow so Ari says put it out Ari
wants it out so bad maybe I'll sell it
to him one day there you go
yeah we're talking if he makes it big
which on the rate he's adding he's big
man he's just [ __ ] sabotaging himself
left and [ __ ] right he's the guy that
killed Kobe Ryan pretty much yeah you
know and a lot of yeah and a lot of
poorly written articles you know here's
the guy and look at this the guy was
flying now helicopters picture of Ari
sometimes you know what I say and it's
bad like bro things get mixed up out
there it's a mash-up yeah he's so
talented man and I think that when he
does film the special called Jew I think
it's called because he's a Jewish
supremacist he's a Jewish yeah 100% when
he's films this special I think it's
gonna be huge
and I think people I think it'll really
I think people will see the the artist
as opposed to like the comic that we've
all known right the sensitive sweet
[ __ ] hilarious
Ari Shaffir as opposed to bloody ass rag
by the way that's still part of his
personalities Doug Stanhope of piss on
you and he's one of the most genius
comics in the world yeah it's like you
can be both people you can give me three
things you mean four things yeah yeah
yeah I don't know we didn't I like I
remember asking if you wanted to talk
about it one day on the podcast and just
through texting and then I never heard
back from him about it but yeah it's
interesting because if I if I here's
what here's what you should do if you
talk to him make him talk honestly right
because this here's what here's what
is frustrating to me is that the cop
it's not even frustrating
it's not even frustrating at all but
like the part of Ari that apologized and
the part that I talked to on the phone
at the end of the month when we hadn't
spoken for a month and he had texted me
every single day going like I want to
talk to you I can't have this happen I
can't lose you as a friend like that guy
right that guy talking about it and
talking about his experience dude that
way is so [ __ ] fascinating the part
of him were it's where he shuts off and
de flex and goes what was a joke right
you know that for me I'm not super
fascinated by but man I know that I know
the man very [ __ ] well yeah and the
sensitive side I would love to hear his
perspective of it from more human space
and now he was here because it's funny
still like his like hit me and him
talking the first time we talked I was
driving to a plan of fitness in an uber
and me and him talk I can see that and
we were just back and forth get kind of
having our first conversation in a month
but giggling and kind of like like yeah
that was a [ __ ] you like I'd say
something like and then instead of going
like deflected he was [ __ ] but you
know what that's me asking him in to do
comedy and that's offensive
right me to go hey this is how you
should talk about it my point is I would
look that side of alright I would love
to hear on a podcast right right oh yeah
man I mean yeah he's definitely a sweet
nice dude I think you know says this
wild character that is though he is God
is this outlaw he's like the Jesse James
kind of like things I can't you can't
change that that's his whole thing and
that's a real thing no yeah it's really
[ __ ] on Bobby Lee's car yeah he beat up
Bobby Lee four times there's a part of
Ari that's a [ __ ] legit wild card I
let me tell you so how do you beat up I
believe three times and then go back and
beat him up one more time now I don't
know I mean it seems like it was an easy
fight dude or lower cuts any cuts dude
any cuts you could use a bobby bobby
[ __ ] BAM Bobby Lee Bobby Lee's so
cool no deaf unbelievable evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watches one